like it's weird to be on a show why
would you guys start we're not right now
I'm sure absolutely yeah a lot of good
stuff came out before we got here
uh well guys I'm coming in hot oh God
so this morning and I do remember a
tremendous amount of
um of audience pushback on this
particular episode uh if I recall
correctly and my hot take is that
they're all wrong oh uh I'm uh with you
not only uh do I think uh it's a great
episode I think it's one of the best
episodes we've ever done
now that's a hot tank that's a hotter
take than I've got but I I think it's up
there with them with a very good episode
I think it's within the top five to ten
minutes
it's 20. it's one of my favorite cold
opens ever I think the cold open is
amazing they're called over to somebody
because you stretch out that moment
where you where you guys are doing
something absurd for so long like we're
talking about the picture George
Washington do you remember who we were
saying it looked like that the network
made us change and we switched it to
Meryl Streep oh no wait wait wait okay
let's try let's I remember somebody to
remember wait let's try let's try and
figure this out so so and they made us
change it Barbara Bush oh no no it has
to be it had to be somebody on FX right
that's right yeah yeah oh Glenn Close
because because of Damages yeah
it does look a little like Glenn Close
it doesn't look anything like Meryl
Streep and it's not as fun and that's my
only
yes there's only
two things that I feel like keep it from
being a perfect episode
that joke or my God damn it should have
been going close it's so much better
and uh and my performance
um and well mine and Danny's storyline
but we'll get into that because there
was a thing with that I do remember yeah
I do remember that too and I want to get
your feelings on that now because yeah
in retrospect because I remember a
member being a thing that we were
talking about on the day trying to dial
that in yeah we'll work to that but like
in terms of the episode in general
that's such a great premise these guys
they have this bar and they want to get
more customers so they say hey if we
were just on a historical walking tour
people would walk by our bar they come
in they have some drinks that's right
and then they go to the historical
society and tell us
ridiculous tale and then well I don't
know I do have I just said I love that
that basically what we're saying to her
is we had a direct hand in our bar had a
direct hand in why the Liberty Bell was
cracked right now
I love the way of course she would be
she's so she's so good she's terrific
yeah she's a woman that works at the
Historical Society and we're saying
we're coming in with a fresh story and
she was so excited to hear it but yeah
we don't we don't tell a story about how
the Liberty Bell get crack got cracked
until the very very end and it's just
these two dudes and I think they were
weren't they like stunt guys or whatever
and they were carrying that thing and
then one guy's like ah [ __ ] bro we just
broke the Liberty Bell
to me it's firing on all cylinders where
it's I don't know I don't know if I feel
as strongly uh about it as you guys do I
liked it I enjoyed it very much uh just
remember purely entertaining standpoint
the fact that we got the production
quality of the show to kind of pull that
off yeah another shot it's very
expensive yeah this is a big swing first
The Paddy set looked outstanding yeah
but the two of you guys and David and uh
and Caitlyn are firing on all cylinders
I'll say that Danny my storyline isn't
as strong as you guys storyline that's
true there's not like much happening
there so I think maybe that just kicks
it out of maybe one of the best we've
done but God damn it I I left beginning
that yeah I think that whole gun
sequence is so funny though
when she's gonna shoot the pumpkin off
of his head and then you guys are
checking if the guns work by pointing
them at each other
it's like oh so funny Charlie asking how
she could have possibly talked you into
this Frank and he's like maybe it was
her nephromancy and she was like yeah
shoot the guns and I said yes that's it
that's why we're here
I like that they're slightly simpler
people they're even simpler than our
characters which are already simple
your reaction to Cricket saying but you
don't really think she's a witch like
it's totally honestly yeah yeah no no
pretty sure she is yeah yeah pretty sure
where where he says I'm not very good
with women and you guys are like well
yeah good at women
they don't have any rights just catch
them
we're like so funny you're kind of going
between like a [ __ ]
story that these guys are telling but
also like who they would have been in
this time which is fun to see yes and
the fact that they're like well the
first thing we're gonna do is try to get
on the British side is so yes so
exciting to the characters also fitting
to Dee that she wants Independence
unless the dependence comes with land
and gowns and jewelry in which case
she's totally fine being married to some
guy but uh yeah although she's got to
work up to kiss again recollection
though of like pitching this episode or
like how we got to wanting to do I mean
for where we were at with the show it is
a big swing which is probably why it was
jarring to audiences which is like they
have to you know suspend their disbelief
beyond what they're already doing but
like
I don't even remember how do we get like
now it would seem normal to be like yeah
we might do one like that but at the
time I can tell you where I do
understand the audience is higher I I
would say that what as the maker of
stuff I like to stretch and do different
things that makes it fun but as as a as
a fan or as a viewer of a show I
actually sometimes do get frustrated
when they get outside of the norm of
what the episode like what the episodes
are cakes yeah yes exactly that's a
great example yeah in in The Sopranos or
the or the episode where Tony moves is a
dream sequence and moves to Los Angeles
and becomes like an average guy sure
you're watching it and you're like I get
why this is exciting to them because
it's different and they get to stretch
and tell a story in a different way the
fly episode very famous in the leather
coat punch the Jukebox and make it work
you don't want to see them jump over the
Sharks but I will say though about this
episode we're not doing that it's
they're just telling a tale right so
that's why for me it's that's why it
works because because it's our
characters making something up and
visualizing ourselves they're just
telling the security and then the
audience gets to go along with this I'm
just playing Devil's Advocate they're
dead wrong the audience is wrong no I
think to be angry
disagree you can [ __ ] off that's our
show right no learn learn something
today learn that you're wrong
um no but like uh
but that's why the people tune into the
podcast let's say they want to learn
let's give credit to the many millions
of people who I'm sure love that episode
too I don't want to say that my dad
loves that loves the episode it's one of
his favorite episodes uh I gotta ask him
why that is I don't know I think he I
think he actually appreciated that we
took like a weird historical angle on on
things I don't know yeah I don't think
that it's hated I think it's just
polarizing I think people either really
like it or they don't like it and they
skip that one in like the rotation let
me throw this in there that if if you're
one of those creeps or or listeners that
skips that episode when you do a
re-watch give it another shot you know
you might your opinion on it may have
changed or maybe not I don't know you
may still come out the other side hating
it but uh give it another shot I don't
remember the breaking of it at all I
don't remember how it got pitched in the
room or
um I don't even remember feeling like oh
this is a big swing or I think it
started with the the concept of trying
to get Patties on a historical tour to
drama business like I think that's how
it started and then and then I think it
went to like well what if we actually
tell the story like what if we actually
do an episode that takes place in the
time that our characters are referring
to uh I I do believe that that is how it
evolved and I think we got very excited
because we were like oh that would be
really fun and totally different so I
remember so here's my thing with my
performance in that which I'm going
there's different takes of me playing it
kind of much more like Charlie Kelly
yeah and then me playing it like this
this kind of like you know
monstrously dumb like frighteningly dumb
guy right which was my initial instinct
which was to be like okay what would the
1776 version of this guy who's already
an idiot be like how
how kind of Base could I make the guy if
you're illiterate in 2005. yeah what
would you be in 17th yeah
um but you guys were just doing your
characters in those costumes right well
sort of we were we were hopping in and
out with like we were right you do the
eye and stuff but like you're not we
would be like our sort of like
heightened versions of uh you know and
then and then something would happen I'd
be like oh yeah good one nice one yeah
right yeah good one witch
and I had done a full day I think or
like full couple scenes of that and then
you guys kind of pulled me aside and be
like hey I feel like I'm not seeing any
Charlie I remember you saying I think
you were being nice and trying to like
soften the blow but being like you're
doing such a good job I don't see any of
your character in there it was like
you're playing a different character
you're playing actually to shackman's
credit he was the one that was picking
up on it first he's such a great
director and he like came to us and was
like I think I'm look I never he never
wants to get in the way of any of our
perform is right so I remember him
saying I don't want to step on Charlie's
performance because it's great but I'm
not seeing a ton of Charlie Kelly in
there what do you guys think and I
remember us discussing it and then
bringing it to you yeah and
B and you guys were dead right I think
it would have that my side of the story
would work better if I just played it
straight like Charlie Kelly
um I could be wrong but like I think I
didn't need anything beyond just me and
Frank being me and Frank in different
costumes with Furs and pumpkins yeah I
think I think I recall it feeling it
feeling a little like I had on a hat
right like I was like it's already
really funny what you guys are doing and
saying it's all you know and then
yeah I think that's how I think that's
how I felt about it because I I remember
also agreeing that I actually liked what
you were doing I just felt like it would
be funnier if you didn't do it right
yeah yeah no yeah I'm saying like yeah I
know and like uh it was one of those
things two words it's hard to know right
we don't know the and there are no rules
right like Cricket is a completely
different guy but it works because he's
this British guy and it's this like
fantasy of cricket
um also the way you guys treat him is
similar yeah similar D not being
interested in him and calling him crazy
ugly it mightn't be me too being like
well there's not a storyline is like
we're trying to buy a pumpkin and then
there's a funny thing with the guns but
like there's not much to that storyline
to try to make more out of it but you
can really see it in the very for the
first time you speak so it's it was
probably an early take in that first
scene
no my good gentleman what says you of my
fine Furs here Mary thee I'd be able to
guide you towards some interest in some
purchase I can't understand what you're
saying you want to buy a farm yeah you
can see you going for it there but I
find myself watching it and remembering
that entire sequence happening and then
going oh man I wouldn't mind seeing a
whole episode yeah that yeah I didn't
know it's something yeah yeah I'd like
I'd love to do a side by side like do it
yeah like if there was a cut of like
full that you know versus like what we
wound up doing was that I would do one
take as that and then several takes were
that dialed so that we have the option
but then what will end up happening I
think is we had one day of shooting
where it was fully that is that it's
kind of in and out of that like
sometimes it's that sometimes it's not
that yeah which I think it doesn't
totally not it doesn't it it doesn't
feel completely disjointed I see it
because I know what we did and it's fine
because we're all doing some characters
at times and then dropping it but
um that re-watching it being like yeah
no I feel like you guys were totally
right like it should have been like just
do it as
Charlie Kelly well so do you guys
remember so
uh went I I do remember when we were
when we were uh writing the episode of
Breaking the episode talking about what
we wanted those guns to look like and
and we very specifically you and I had
the same image I I you know all of us
did when you say Blunderbuss yeah
they look like actual rifles and we're
like well this isn't this ain't fun
this is what they actually used in 1776
yeah yeah I don't [ __ ] care we don't
give a [ __ ] bring us what we wrote in
the script and they're like [ __ ]
this is what you wrote in the script and
we're like well don't bring us what we
were thinking
there is a lot of that there is a lot of
that what we're thinking
don't bring us what we asked for right
because didn't didn't we determine that
there were no actual guns made with
quite the dimensions that Eleanor
[Laughter]
there was also another incident uh with
this episode where where we were saying
we want Cricket's head to explode in a
very specific way well do you remember
what the reference was I do but at the
time do you remember we were like we we
know exactly what we wanted to be we
wanted to explode in a billion pieces
and they're like well that just can't be
done and we were like well no we we've
seen David Cronenberg did it in the
1970s yeah so we saw it in Scanners and
we were like make it like we want a
scanners explosions yeah I mean so no
but for the audience anybody who's you
know David Cronenberg fan certainly but
if you have seen the movie scanners
there is a very famous scene you should
put that in there I believe it's Michael
ironside's head oh is it ah or maybe
ironside's doing it I can't remember
Ironsides involved in some way love that
guy uh very broad shoulders I worked
with him on a computer identity I was in
one of my community episodes he's
terrific he told great stories about
some movie he was on with like Arnold
Schwarzenegger Total Recall yeah Total
Recall he was talking about being in a
room and they just the cigarette smoke
like that they would in order to get the
room Smoky back then to like shoot with
atmosphere not only did they used to
smoke but there used to be buckets of
cigarettes just like smoking into the
room to like get it okay well that's
ridiculous because smoke machines
definitely existed but that's like
apropos of what we're talking about here
so we were so we were saying great make
it look like scanners and the visual the
special effects guys were like we can't
do that and we were like what are you
talking about it's 30 years later and
they're like well no the way that they
got that because we want to there's a
couple of takes that we actually did
where the head I think we had three
heads and the two takes did not work
because the pyrotechnic just didn't work
it just kind of we were just like fell
apart and our special effects guy was
like look the way that they did that
because he researched it was the guy
came in with a shotgun yeah and right
off camera just blew the head away to
the shotgun and we were like let's do
that and he was like
you can't do that
it's not it's not the 1970s so at the
same time when they were burning
cigarettes on sets they were taking
shotguns so they were just hot guns and
live rounds on set blowing heads up
probably had a cigarette in his mouth
right yeah sure so how did we I don't
remember and we were by the way that was
the first time we shot with the Phantom
that was the first time he upped the
load
the first one was like 30 percent so it
was like 60 and then he put in like and
we had everybody to leave and put on ear
protection and [ __ ] and he essentially
just I mean he blew the thing up with
like the force of and it was is that if
that's funny In My Memory he shot it
with a shotgun now yeah right now now in
Scanners uh I believe I I feel like the
face like it explodes but the face
actually like Flats you know like a
really interesting way which we have
which we have in here the the Horn's
bone
and I shall make sure that all of you
are safe from the mighty sword
[ __ ]
God damn it Frank you just ruined my
whole life
check his pulse
yeah a good chunk of videos flies off
the side but well you then you see an
eye you get a great eyeball just an
eyeball goes you know part of the shame
of it though is like having to use the
different camera just to get the slow
shot so then it jumps so much that I
feel like it's a little less surprising
it's still well that's because you're
like part of how silly it looks you can
definitely see that it's oh yeah yeah
there's a Charlie being like well check
his pulse
that comes out of his neck
is pulse wait wait wait wait wait check
his pulse that was in the script yeah
speaking of effects how did you guys get
Rob's wooden teeth to make that noise
acting yeah you're acting in general
abstracting is amazing
you've had many many good ones but I
think it's one of your best the two of
you guys together all those scenes
you hang back what me why
because we need to get as much Intel
from these guys as we possibly can for
that Colonel Cricket spot thing's gonna
totally blow our cover what's going on
with your mouth oh I got some Wooden
Teeth did you yeah well all the Patriots
are doing it including Washington which
is why it makes sense okay if we're
going undercover not just thought
[ __ ] no the [ __ ] thing's good man I
gotta plan with it yeah got an angle
fine okay you let me take the lead okay
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah son of a [ __ ]
but yeah the wooden teeth is such a
funny how did you how did you do that
that's not actually T there's no teeth
in there it's my teeth just painted
painted brown so I was just doing it
with like a like a whistle are you
making that whistle noise yeah
and then we would add yeah so that's
exactly right so I so yeah so what were
some of the like some of the lines and
then we would and then what I did was in
post I just went like
the combination of that guy and then
your fop and that first scene where you
go to the revolutionaries and then
you're like what are we talking about
and you're like surrendered
I think the whistle's making the whole
yeah the whistles the whole thing yeah
it's the whole thing making it work as a
male trainer Matt Vincy playing the uh
uh one of the Patriots right
um but he he seems like a patriot he
seems like a real Patriot yeah in real
life he's you think he's a big Patriot
and so he just comes off like a
patriotism
yeah it seems like he could kick butt
for America you know square jaw
where you guys seem like traitors and
fox yeah
yeah that's about that sounds about
right yeah did it take longer to shoot
this episode probably there's no way we
have to redress the whole bar yeah which
was a big deal but once it was dressed
once the sets were all built it wasn't
it wasn't super complicated where'd you
shoot all that stuff that was like out
in the marketplace and stuff
um Lacy Street Studios and it was uh not
a nice Studio no
um kind of rough around the edges and we
just brought in the dirt and the
chickens but they had a lot of like
brick and stuff yeah but I mean all that
stuff had to be built it had to be you
know and yeah enough of it to where we
could do an actual walk and talk we
should we then we shoot some of it in um
Pasadena yes and then you guys going
down the alleyway where Dave G yeah
corner is you guys that's the alleyway
in Pasadena and then and then and then
we shot in front of Patty's and then we
shot in front of patties and we just put
dirt down and
I was watching the movie judgment night
last night and there is absolutely
there's a shot when the when the when
the the RV breaks down in that movie
it's right next to it's they drive right
by patties you know it's another good
classic like downtown movies Repo Man
and yeah it's all like the streets where
we shoot Sunny Emilio Estevez only shot
Knights right yeah he's like is it night
is it downtown L.A I'm in I'm in
um are there any small Ducks involved
are they Mighty
um
uh Dave G our buddy Dave G who had
already been in an episode because he
was in
um the gang sells out he plays somebody
who works at the oldies Rock Cafe he's
played a number of characters well so he
played the oldies Rock Cafe guy with the
he had like a little thing and he is
giving D the resume right yeah and then
we brought him back for the Liberty Bell
he plays the the Cockney guy who accosts
us and he's credited as thug thug thug
and then he comes back again so Dave's
played three characters on the show Dave
G that's got a good record oh and then
also uh the courtyard where you guys go
to meet David for the first time and you
bring him to a that was an Alta Dina
yeah that was in La Canada oh oh that
was in La Canada I got an old like kind
of mansion wait do you know are you sure
that that was in La Canada yeah was it
was it like a gated community is La
Canada near Altadena yeah they're close
yeah because I thought it was Altadena
yeah it's up that way okay see I had a
memory and maybe this was actually a
different episode this might have been
the Gang
this might have been the gang gets
trapped in the closet but maybe if you
guys remember this
um
a very famous person lived that was
Trapped in the Closet that was trapped
in the closet and that's down off
Wilshire but okay yeah that's over okay
so we'll save we'll save that Jesus for
a guy who doesn't remember about you he
remembers a lot Charlie's on top
you know why because it's near the golf
course that that house is near the golf
course which he remembers no the one in
wheelchair did you try to by the way so
is the La Canada did you take a
limitless pill this morning
I have no limits this morning what else
do you want to remember
[Music]
Glenn a look like you've been working
out oh man thanks dude yeah I mean look
I'm always working out you know so I'm
not sure if you just now notice me is
like a compliment or not because um I've
been I've been working out a lot too
yeah
it's the sort of person that needs to do
that to feel good about themselves what
are you guys wearing to work out these
days what are you what are you looking
good in mainly I'm looking for
versatility and comfortability all right
something that will fit any workout I
might be doing that day I may be running
I might be swimming training or yoga and
that's why I love the core shorts from
Biore oh my God the viori shorts yeah
yeah guys I don't go anywhere near the
gym without my viewers I mean I love
them they look and they and they feel
great as you move in them plus you know
what I love their products are made from
sustainable materials and offsets 100 of
its carbon and plastic footprint so you
can feel great about what you're wearing
fiori is an investment in your happiness
for our listeners they are offering 20
off your first purchase guys get
yourself some of the most comfortable
and versatile clothing on the planet at
viore.com
Sunny pod yeah that's
v-u-o-r-i.com slash Sunny pod uh you get
20 off your first purchase uh but enjoy
free shipping on any U.S orders over 75
dollars and free returns you know if it
doesn't fit goes back free go to
viore.com Sunny pod and discover the
versatility of that fiori clothing man
we're brought to you this week by
Shopify for when you're ready to launch
your thing into the spotlight and here
to attest our three guys we uh who we
all know because they launched their
thing into the spotlight yeah that's
right we launched our things are things
into the spotlight I don't know well we
did our television show and everybody is
familiar with that origin story by now
but I have to say if we did it again we
might launch ourselves onto a different
platform oh a different platform like
Shopify absolutely it's been a good run
on cable but I feel like culture is
Shifting towards a platform ethos like
Shopify you create a store based on your
own Vibe discover new customers that dig
your Vibe and grow a following that
keeps coming back week in and week out
yeah plus Shopify has all the sales
channels sorted to keep your business
growing from an in-person POS system to
an all-in-one e-commerce platform
even across social media platforms like
Tick Tock Facebook or Instagram
launching our thing into the spotlight
has always been a dream from a very
young age but I will say uh it has its
share of pitfalls and learning curves it
would have been a lot easier with
shopify's 24 7 support and free
libraries of educational content Shopify
makes it simple to sell to anyone
anywhere and every minute new sellers
around the world make their first sale
on Shopify let's just jump to it you
know what sign up for a free trial today
at shopify.com Sunny all lowercase yep
go to shopify.com Sunny to start selling
online today I'ma say it one more time
shopify.com Sunny
[Music]
you know right now
we're writing the show again yeah just
started we just started writing the show
again we just started Wednesday I don't
know when this podcast this is coming
out next Monday yeah okay so we're on
day two of writing um and Rob Rozelle
and Scott martyr are back this year in
the writers room
um which is really exciting very
exciting very exciting I will say when I
look up at that list of episodes I think
we've discussed this so you guys feel
the same way that
um the closer they are to the present
the uh the the least I remember them I
remember the for I could name you every
episode from seasons one through three
or four and then then it starts to get
and then the closer it gets to I like
season 14 I have no idea but is that
because we just rewatched them for the
podcast I don't think so I think it's
because we spent so much more time
making them because we were figuring out
what the show was yeah I think it was a
much more all-consuming experience in
the early years because you're figuring
it out yeah and everything matters every
decision is
longer right so like whatever gang
cracks the Liberty Bell has been
discussed and quoted and talked about
you know for a longer period of time
memes there's been they've been sort of
like put into society in a way that like
last year
you know the one with the monkey you
know is it's just newer it's just not
been in your life as as long so like I
remember yeah but I I think I mean
personally I think it has more to do
with sort of where you're at in life
where you're you know it's it's like
yeah like you got a lot more going on
now too like uh children children
multiple shows versus what we were all
airing every whole life was yeah it was
a show report we were pouring absolutely
everything into it and it and it and it
took longer because yeah we were
figuring it out so so I think that's why
because every decision felt Monumental
this period that we're in right now in
the writer's room is my favorite part
the blue skying at the beginning it's
always the most fun because you're just
like throwing a bunch of weird ideas
explain the audience what what that is
yeah so blue skying so the first like
what we usually only do like a week of
this on sunny but most shows the first
couple weeks you just throw out episode
ideas so it could be like little tiny
ideas like full fully formed it episodes
I used to do that when I prepared more
for my first day but now you guys can't
fire me so I come in with like half
ideas
eventually responsible for your lack of
preparation in the beginning because I
think you have you got to make up for it
over the course of the next but it's fun
because then like so Rob was sitting in
with index cards and any idea that you
guys liked he would just write it down
we'd put it up on the board so that
there's all these cards up on the board
that might have ideas like what well the
Judgment night thing that you guys got
onto and you're really excited about for
next year or that's right I'm coming to
talk about yeah so what so why do we get
into judgment night we got into judgment
night because of relevance we were
talking about being relevant and our
music choices being relevant and we
talked about how the Judgment Night
soundtrack was a seminal experience for
people over the age of 44. right right
yeah that was like a huge album yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was it was one of
those it was one of those out it was
like that and like The Crow soundtrack
Dangerous Minds Dangerous Minds have
been like a couple of soundtracks back
in the day that that really cut through
and and then had like a huge cultural
impact I don't know so that got us
talking about Cypress Hill right right
and singing Cypress Hill songs and then
half the room was like who oh
yeah yeah
not half our room I have our room's all
old Megan uh there were a couple things
where Nina was turning to me she was
like Nina was like
Davis she Davis yeah I think maybe
that's why sometimes when we go through
these episodes and I ask you where the
ideas came from it's so hard to remember
specifically because it is so amorphous
in a writer's room like where I like
that judgment night thing might turn
into an episode that you could never
believe started with a conversation
about the Judgment Night soundtrack and
then became something completely
different we could just lose the whole
judgment night things totally but it
inspires something I mean also like yeah
it was interesting we're talking about
that and like in judgment night they've
rented like a Winnebago and they're
trying to get to a boxing match and they
pull over because traffic's bad and then
they're like in a bad neighborhood and
then they like see a murder and then
they're like you know it's like a very
kind of
genre based like fight your way out of
yeah out of hell kind of thing but like
I don't know that there's there's such a
problem with homelessness and there was
something interesting about the idea of
like literally driving around in like a
second home yeah you know yeah and then
trying to cut through like a homeless
encampment yeah in your home yeah
your mobile second home
committing the murder
instead of seeing the murder we think
we've committed the murder and we have
to run over our homelessness with your
other home and then we have to get out
of here well that that's how that that
is what happens in in judgment night um
sort of I mean to say he's not a
homeless guy but he's like running for
help that was just shot but that was an
accident yeah no it wasn't that total
accident and then they they rescue the
guy thinking that it's because they hit
him then they discovered that he's been
shot and then they find like money on
him and they're like oh [ __ ] what is
what are we about to get wrapped up in
and then Dennis Leary shows up and
doesn't he he he's doesn't he finish him
off shoot him in the head yeah yeah he
sure does I mean he really
you know got his career to an
interesting place right he should end up
right where he got to do like dramatic
stuff and yeah he's a good actor I I
wonder yeah I'd love to actually I I
don't know if he started as an because
some people like you you think that they
were stand-ups but they actually were
actors first and then they just happened
to do stand-up like you know I think for
people who don't know that like Robin
Williams went to Juilliard they're like
oh he was a stand-up comedian and then
he became an actor I was like no he was
an actor first then he started doing
stand-up because he was so funny I do
remember I I think it was uh
maybe the last season of Rescue Me and
we saw Dennis Larry I don't remember if
you I think we were all there and we ran
into Dennis Leary in a hallway I think
he was at a TCA event oh yeah and he was
like that's right very effusion in the
vowels of the TCA yeah yeah and and he
was he was super nice and effusive and
and it was really cool because I one of
my first
what was it my first no I think it was
my second on camera gig it might be
offensive offensive at the time
it was definitely offensive at the time
but did you talk about this the job yeah
yes so I don't think we've talked about
it on the podcast so yeah it was it was
a show that Dennis Larry did it was a
half hour comedy but it was about cops
and it was called the job and I believe
it was on ABC and uh I remember
auditioning
to going into this audition to play
um a gay uh wedding planner and I
remember I didn't know I was like I I
didn't know like sort of tonally what
they were going for with this so so I
remember going into the audition and and
again this is this is a part that was
like I don't even know if saying this
would be considered offensive but I was
just trying to get a performance note
from the casting director and from the
director and the people that were there
I was like
how gay are we talking like you know
what I mean give me a give me a Range
you know like how cartoonish how much of
a stereotype are we looking for
we want to make the situation better or
worse just socially yes okay yes am I
making fun of this entire group of uh
yeah no I no it was literally I was like
I was like I just did just draw you know
uh one you were basing him on a real
person well okay that's so yes that is
actually true but that okay that came
after they said like I was like on a
scale you know on a scale of one to ten
you know how how effeminate you want
this man to be uh and they were like
and 11. what and I was like 11.
are you sure uh and they were like a
bunch of straight people in a room being
like let's go for it yeah go for it
let's just see I think they just wanted
to see what an 11 was sure you know what
I mean since I actually were like well
since you asked let's see what you got
what's your 11. uh so I gave him an 11
and it was and it was
to be fair totally and 100 based on a a
guy that that uh was in the dance
division at Juilliard at the same time
as me
stopped by Benjamin hark Harvey yeah yes
uh rest in peace
um and so I was basically like I'm just
gonna do that
um because that's an 11. so then when
they were like that they were all they
loved it like wow wow I I I yeah I I
think that I think well I got they hired
me so they they must have liked it
um and then when I went when I actually
shot it I went prepared to like fully be
that guy and when I started shooting it
actually they were like they were like
they had me dial it back so uh what's in
that show is actually like style bass a
seven okay that's a seven Rob what are
you playing your gay character at me
yeah three oh uh as a stereotype yeah
well so that's the question right I mean
you know because uh you can you can
definitely see it as a stereotype you
know uh but I I
was playing essentially a real human
being that I had met and encountered and
talked to and was you know friendly with
so this was a person that I knew this is
a real human being that I was basing
this on so stereotype yeah you could see
it that way for sure you're saying that
oftentimes stereotypes are 100 True no
that's true isn't it not for whole
groups of people but sometimes for
individuals for individual people yeah
yeah I'm not saying it's right to
portray them that way I'm not even
saying that my performance was was
completely dialed in you know uh in that
in that sense but you know for
clarification I was playing a real human
being yes but when you're on that show
are you a big fan of Denis Leary before
you got there was he one of your like
comedy did you grow up like watching
Comedians and like coming in that way or
it was just the acting thing and then
you found comedy it was both I mean I I
at the time I was yeah I know I didn't
consider myself a comedy person at all I
mean I I knew I liked doing comedy I
felt like you know amongst my group of
friends maybe I was I was funny and but
I had a lot of super funny friends and
as you think you've pointed out with
like your buddies in Philly you feel
like you're the least funny person of
all your friends and yet you've made a
career out of it uh I often feel that
way where I'm like I have so many
friends that are so much funnier than me
and yet somehow I've made a career did
you grow up watching a lot of stand up
yeah lots of stand up and how did you
access it
um it's not Comedy Central yeah I have
cable oh okay Comedy Central and also um
I used to watch SNL and then after SNL
was
um uh Showtime at the Apollo yeah and I
used to watch that a lot which was great
and then
um start with the stand up yeah they
started they did some stand-up and some
different acts and stuff the Star Search
that's where Sinbad came out of star
search
um my dad was a big fan of stand up so
he used to play comedy records like Bill
Cosby
the old Richard Pryor and Bill Cosby
then I used to read their books like I I
went through this phase where I would
like go to the library and like check
out any book that was written by like a
stand-up comedian I would like read so
I've read like Tim Allen's book and like
I read the text Leary's book the one
about NyQuil yeah I probably read that
one too the NyQuil isn't the title of
the book yeah a whole act that was based
on NyQuil and how much he loved NyQuil
no I did I did though I I did I admired
him tremendously because I I had seen
his stand-up I wasn't like a huge
stand-up fan but I I knew enough and I
did I remember him standing out to me in
a major way the first time I ever saw
him on MTV I was like holy [ __ ] this guy
is something else like he's somebody was
on the top of their game and you watch
them firing on all cylinder is in front
of a crowd but then he's pretty
compelling it's amazing but then he also
had a stand-up special that really put
him on the map I think was called no
cure for cancer yeah yeah the stand-up
act yeah very smoking the whole time
he's smoking the whole time and it's
hilarious It's [ __ ] amazing and so I
knew him from that and then
um I don't think at the time I really
knew his acting stuff that much but I
just admired him as a as a performer so
yeah it was exciting it was cool I think
he still smokes I don't think he does no
I I don't know Dennis he's still smoking
pal it's time it's time but the stop
smoking thing like it reminds me of I I
recently saw an article about a guy I
can't remember where it was but who
hadn't taken a bath in like 65 years
and we died
yeah and you do think about that you're
like okay let's say a person like ate
bake it like just tons of bacon and like
smoking a ton of cigarettes and like all
this stuff for their entire life and
then if they make a change like do does
your body become so acclimated to that
one way I think so I think if you don't
wean it you know what I mean like he
maybe he shouldn't have taken a full-on
bath maybe just like walk through the
rain first you know or like just wash
your hands
[Music]
hey guys um the Always Sunny podcast is
sponsored by Better Health do you ever
wish life came with an owner's manual
like your vehicle do you struggle to
understand why you're feeling feelings
we should all be feeling feelings every
day but sometimes they get overwhelming
and unfortunately there is no owner's
manual for them but better help online
therapy is basically the next best thing
but the thing is it's true because
therapists you know therapists are
trained to help you figure out the cause
of challenging emotions and to learn
productive coping skills you know which
makes therapy the closest thing to an
Owner's Manual of you therapy is helpful
in all regards and better help has
connected Millions with licensed
therapists it's convenient accessible
anywhere and entirely online as the
world's largest therapy service better
help us match three million people with
professionally licensed and vetted
therapists available 100 percent online
plus it's affordable all you got to do
just fill out a brief questionnaire to
match with a therapist if things aren't
clicking you can easily switch to a new
therapist anytime time it could not be
simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no
endless searching for the right
therapist learn more and save 10 off
your first month at betterhelp.com Sunny
that's right that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p.com slash Sunny
[Music]
this is going back to something we were
talking about earlier but it's
interesting to me to ask you guys so
none of you have ever been in a writer's
room as a writer for somebody else's
show right no no so you've never done a
blue skying like just pitching ideas to
somebody else's thing or have you done
that we did I did pop into the writer's
room a few times uh when Rosa Martin
Roselle when we produced unsupervised
yes that's the one time I've ever spent
some time in a writer's room where I was
like breaking stories and and talking
about story ideas on somebody else's
show even though I wasn't EP on the show
but uh other than that no it's
interesting that like none of you have
ever hard I did that with them too and
I'd be like I think we should go there
and they're like no we should go
somewhere else I'm like
but it seems like I know like we should
go there no we're going this direction
I'm like but that well it's like if you
started out as the lead singer
songwriter in a band right and then
somebody said hey come in and sing
backup vocals for me you know and you
went in you're like well we'll sing it
like this and they're like well no
you're doing backups so you just you're
like
I don't know if it's analogous to that
because you're you you are contributing
it would be like someone's like
it would be like uh Simon and Garfunkel
and and Simon's like well this is the
way we've been doing it and art you've
been helping out with the songwriting
but we're going to do it like this and
then one day he's our Garfunkel's like
no we're going to do it like this and
then Paul Simon's like goodbye
gar [ __ ] off
car [ __ ] yourself go [ __ ] yourself
that's better
it's just interesting to me because like
you guys are great showrunners to work
for and um
yeah and uh they're not paying me to say
this um but uh but but you would think
that that would come because you've
worked in rooms and you know how to
treat people fairly because you've been
but it's just interesting that like you
guys have never been on that side of it
and still treat people with like respect
and dignity when they're in the room
which may be why we treat people with
respect to dignity maybe you know I
think it it could be that you know if
you come out of years of being
demoralized by a showrunner you know and
then you finally get your shot you're
like I find that more often than not the
people if they haven't gone through
something
if they've been mistreated they tend to
mistreat yeah maybe that's that because
they've either that's the way that
they've learned or because they truly
feel like now nothing's often this it's
just who you are right it's like you're
mistreated like on on a show or or like
you know like on a movie or like in a
writer's room
I don't think I would take it very well
I got I've been mistreated but not like
abused in any like real way not in the
way that a lot of people have been
mistreated in this I got it I got have I
told the story of working with that
director in Fargo where with the props
no yeah that's all this story no okay so
I I I've been extremely lucky too I
haven't really run into too many
problems on on sets with like jerks or
or somebody being a jerk to me and I
very much
very much don't wouldn't take it well
and I knew that I wouldn't take it well
and luckily had never encountered it so
never had to deal with it but I was uh
working on an episode of Fargo and there
was a director
who
had just you know I
I don't know he
whatever anyway we were setting up a
scene well I was gonna yeah
he's there right now if you were to take
his blood pressure through the roof no
you're not wrong you're not wrong
um now what does [ __ ] say what's this
it was a scene uh with me and and Billy
Bob and I had to
uh do a thing where okay so the scene
was I had to use one of those like you
know those voice modulators that you put
like on the phone to modulate your voice
records or like this or whatever so my
character is supposed to take this voice
modulator put it on the phone dial dial
the phone and call someone and use the
thing you know
so we're in the rehearsal and you know
we're like well let me rehearse this
with the props just because you know I
want to make sure that it all like so
it's not goofy you know so I have the
voice modulator in one hand and then
I've got to grab the receiver it was one
of those phones where the numbers were
on the thing so this thing was kind of
big and then I've got the receiver in
this hand and I was like
you know and I and and and this is
rehearsal like in front of the crew like
I don't think the whole crew was there
but there were people watching the
rehearsal you know and I was like oh you
know what this is a little awkward
because I'm not sure how I'm supposed if
I've already got this in my hand
uh you know how how am I supposed to
dial the phone you know like with this
thing in my hand and he was like
you've never dialed a phone before and I
was like
and I changed immediately because I knew
what that meant you know that's that's
not a that's not a real question yeah
you know so I think that's what I said
to him I was like is that a real
question
and he was like he was like just you
just dial the phone as you would any
other phone and I was like you've
misunderstood
my question I have something in both
hands
my fingers are occupied so what I'm
saying that you've misunderstood is how
am I supposed to dial a phone with
fingers that I don't have
do you understand my question now
and this guy was like and this guy was
like who the [ __ ] does this guest star
like that was I could tell that was what
he was thinking he's like who the [ __ ]
is this guest star I think he is and I
was like [ __ ] I'll walk off this
set I don't give a [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] no see we respond to that
differently because like my response
would be like okay I'll figure it out
like I just want to like make you
pleased and I was like no you explain it
you explain it because because you seem
to understand how man can a man with no
fingers can use his fingers to dial a
phone so you explain it to me in the
whole [ __ ] crew right now you prick
to your point I get I get when you say
like you want to you want to you you
want to
make a you want to make the environment
as peaceful as possible but if someone
comes at you with that level of disdain
or aggression would you respond the same
way yes well I mean there's two like for
me I'm trying to get better but there's
usually two options one is appease and
like get the situation back to peace
however quickly we can do that or burst
into tears and then leave
you would and have removed yourself from
the situation thought on it and then
eventually acted and called bad behavior
out and which is to say like you you
wouldn't
you wouldn't completely you might take
it in the moment but that doesn't mean
you're totally gonna take different
triggers too right like for some reason
I my biggest trigger uh when it comes to
that kind of thing is if somebody
tries to like and I I'm better about it
now than I used to be when I was younger
I real [ __ ] temper about this but
like if anybody tried to humiliate me
certainly even if even if it wasn't in
front of other people but certainly
if it was like in front of people
that would nothing would set me off more
than like you know somebody trying to
humiliate me because that's what it felt
like it felt like he was trying to
humiliate it and I was like I have had
that happen and at the time like I
didn't do anything about it but you know
what has helped me now is like just
having enough wins like having the
confidence of looking back and like in
particular I'm remembering a showrunner
that I I was on set with one of the
episodes that I'd written and the
showrunner wasn't on set and when we
first screened the episode The editor's
Cut in the writer's room this showrunner
didn't like it and said to me in front
of the whole writer's uh room is this
what you think TV is no no seriously is
this what you think TV is supposed to be
like tell me right now that this is what
you think the TV is supposed to be like
this is what you think it's supposed to
be like and just kept hammering me on
that and I was like I don't even know
what you don't like about it like but
then I but I was really nervous because
I was like oh I [ __ ] up the episode
didn't and it's already been shot so we
can't do anything about it I hate it I
was I immediately was like you should
humiliate me because I've ruined it and
so felt like that until the episode
aired and then it was like one of the
most popular episodes of the show ever
so then now I have the confidence of
looking back at moments like that and
going like well consider the source like
do you think this person is the end-all
be-all of knowing everything about what
TV is if so then you can feel shame for
what but so that that's helped but like
at the beginning yeah I mean I also even
as a guest star you were like famous
enough or or successful enough that you
felt like I could walk out of here and
still have a career but I was like you
know a young writer on a staff I was
like I can't be like [ __ ] you I almost
like walk out of this room yeah I think
to be fair I think yeah this time and
place where yeah I think if I wasn't in
the position if I if I needed if I
desperately needed that job I might have
been able to I might have just swallowed
it a little bit in that moment but uh
but knowing that I didn't but I bet it
ended right after that exchange right
like it shut them down well that's what
happened
with bullies right because he became
very nice after that they don't bully a
guy like you
especially if they know oh this guy's
Not Gonna Take It yeah they bully
someone like Megan who's in her first
year yeah it's like uh you know famous
directors who've heard have like
terrible tempers and you see like clips
of them like freaking out on somebody on
set and you're like well they're not
freaking out on the guy that can kick
the living [ __ ] out of them yeah
bullets bully writ large but to bring it
bring it around back to like this
episode and taking big swings and stuff
I think that the real shame of doing
stuff like that I'm trying to humiliate
somebody like being like a shitty boss
is that you like
you kind of suffocate that person's
ability to just like try things you
gotta Kick around some bad ideas to get
to a good one also my half idea might
merge with somebody else's half idea and
then become like but if I never say it
out loud it never I feel like almost
every episode of our show yeah is like a
result of like some weird conversation
about like you know some [ __ ] dumb
there's a balance though right like if
you feel all your pitches are going over
like a lead balloon sure then you should
probably should pick up on that and be
like all right let me let me think
through these a little bit more before I
pitch them yeah I think but yeah well
I'm trying to certainly pitch Sunny
ideas to you guys not like any random
idea that I you know I try to to tailor
it to the people that I'm pitching to
and yeah I feel like I know you guys a
little bit now so let's a little bit
successful yesterday in the writer's
room I feel like I got some things on
note cards no okay no I'll try again
and is that well a lot of them I'm
thinking like is that we can tell me
yeah
we should pull that out at some point
today
let's go ride the show
thank you